[Music]
we went to little tokyo to do a quick
little test see how to hide waldo he did
well but every single person looked at
us specifically every single person
looked at wren in the waldo costume yeah
everyone was coming up saying hey waldo
i found you everyone no one really
understands just how well known waldo is
i'm having issues
for whatever reason the top view
was out of sync by like 15 seconds can
you just manually sync the top one
yeah
i think it finally worked
compared to everything i've gotten so
far this is actually
really solid
i'm behind this watermark
that's pretty good
literally you just lift up the entire
rig and just like spin it in circles oh
geez it's weird yeah well although
where's brown boots i honestly don't
think the shoes are that big of a deal i
don't understand why this is even a
conversation
brent's fine with the shoes no one's
gonna say hey hold
on that's not well done
where's your brown boots
i see what you did there no waldo has
brown boots uh-huh
uh-huh wait have you talked to james
so whenever we go into a video that
requires us to do pretty like extreme
gorilla shooting especially when it's
like interacting with the public as like
fbi agents i always get a little anxious
a little worried that somebody's gonna
think i'm like about to assault them or
like blow up a bomb or something like
that
so how exactly do you plan on getting on
campus across the street you walk
through there and you walk through this
square one security guard stops us and
asks us for ids then we're screwed
[Music]